kate wang is ceo and co-founder of
chinese vaping company relaxed
technology
and is worth an estimated 3.6 billion
dollars
she's just one of a record 57 self-made
women billionaires from china
and one of the youngest at just 40 years
old
wang grew up in xi'an one of the oldest
cities in china
she had a quiet childhood and liked to
read books
she went to college in her hometown
graduating with a degree in finance
she moved around a bit working as a
management trainee at procter
gamble in guangzhou then co-founded an
investment firm in hong kong
but she was hungry for more and moved to
new york to get her mba from colombia
next stop beijing where she spent a year
as a consultant
followed by four years in uber china and
chinese ride-hailing service
dede chushing where she worked on the
business side helping to normalize the
concept of ride sharing in hangzhou
in the midst of all this kate picked up
a cigarette habit but was embarrassed by
it
changing her clothes immediately after
to hide the smell
she didn't want to end up like her
father who was trying to quit but was
still smoking two cigarette packs a day
she tried vaping calling most of the
products on the market at the time
terrible but it was something she wanted
to solve
and there was a wide open market of
adults just like her and her dad
struggling to quit she gave her two
weeks and recruited five of her
colleagues to join her new venture
crowdfunding and pitching itself as a
tech startup
their product was sleek and instead of
the traditional tobacco and mint flavors
they offered ludo ice
a mung bean popsicle flavor after just a
little more than a year in operation
they had half of china's domestic vaping
market
within three years they were the largest
e-cigarette brand in china
relax went public on the new york stock
exchange in january
making kate and her three other
co-founders overnight billionaires
cigarettes were of course bad for kate
wang's health but vaping
so so good for her wealth